hey everyone welcome to visual effects
artists react oh we have some incredible
Clips first off aess actors randomly on
a blue
screen oh good
lord excuse me sir have you guys ever
wondered what it would be like to die by
having your multiverses unravel wow I
love it there's so many ways to approach
this because you know you're looking at
these incredibly high density High
detail simulations I have a treat for
you guys today I have some of the
greatest ocean visual effects in cinema
history from m and Commander now I must
say that shot was amazing wait a minute
we have a special bonus section today
it's called Sam's video game Unreal
Engine Corner well it's a really hot
corner to be in right now and I'll show
you
[Music]
why today I am declaring United States
of America's first war on
crime so somebody in the comments
suggested we should take a look at
Public Enemies starring Johnny Depp
looking for a janky head replacement
shot oo I love those you like you now do
it do it hold the floor now now ooh wa
that's uncanny that's freaky is that
like a 3D model yeah oh yeah it is I
think what's so interesting about this
one is that it's it's such an
unnecessary shot it's not the VFX artist
fault this is the director's fault for
choosing to do a shot like that they're
like Mr Depp jump over this and he's
like no it's like fine you stuntman you
do it and we'll put your face on there
later people have been making movies for
years you have a stunt double it's like
there's ways you film a stunt double you
know not like face incoming at camera
you could have just skipped that shot
yeah hey for all you know like the VFX
soup or producers like it'll work we got
it what is it about the face too it's
like dead eyes aside it's it's dead eyes
dead eyes the skin is like it's there's
no sub surface scattering at the end of
the day there's nothing it's just he got
that waxy Scorpion King Vibe yeah and
what's funny too is if you just sit on a
still like after a while it stopped
being as uncanny to me yeah totally like
now that I've stared at it for a while
I'm like yeah that's the challenge but
the minute it moves it's uncanny again a
lot of people probably just don't even
notice it yeah but but how we we noticed
it I I noticed it immediately to be fair
you are sitting on the couch filming a
show called bfx a react your guard is
that no I have I have an idea hold on
lower your guard real quick okay I'm
watching this movie it's Michael man I'm
sick of watching this movie cuz it's
filmed with digital cameras uh but lower
the guard lower the guard needs to be
lower you don't know anything about
digital camera here with someone very
important to me and I don't want to be
rude and leave the movie so I'm just
going to watch it all right it is all
right what's going to happen they're
going to rob this oh I love bank
robberies yes El Capone yes Mafia sweet
yeah the shot's
fine problem solved just lower the guard
in the standards that's it and like if
there's no other CG in the movie that
one shot probably would not catch you
yeah it's just everything else like that
like random blue screenshot of Johnny
Depp excuse
me excuse me sir I noticed that yeah oh
good lord good Lord What's Happening
Here is they're on this set which is a
different set than the bang Vault set
guarantee it they don't cut and they go
to the spot where the Vault would be
which is just a blue screen and they're
comping in the vault again it's
unnecessary decisions like that will
cost you thousands of dollars and it's
like is it worth thousands of dollars
will people pay more money will we get
more people to see this movie if you
don't cut and spin the camera or if you
just cut and we don't have to worry
about doing visual effects yeah now
Johnny debt may not have needed a face
replacement but what you do need is a
website replacement and you can do that
with today's sponsor Squarespace now
many of you may not know but I existed
before I showed up on this channel I was
a real human in the real world I was
doing a lot of freelance visual effects
and if you're going to sell yourself
online you need a website and I use
Squarespace for mine I have certain
skill sets in design website is not one
of them but they got you covered there
because they offer award-winning
templates then you can customize your
look update the content and add features
to fit your unique needs now for me it
was visual effects a skill set but if
you're not selling a skill set and
instead selling a product they still got
you covered you can sell your products
on an online store whether you sell
physical digital or service products
Squarespace has the tools you need to
start selling online today and if you
have more to offer on your website you
can even create member only areas where
you can house all the real goodies you
know one-on ones private courses
exclusive content I did that with my
eyebrows but it doesn't have to be that
kind so if you are looking to start a
website and grow your brand Squarespace
has you covered you can hit that link in
the description or head over to
squarespace.com Corridor crew for 10%
off your first domain or website and if
that deal sounds unreal wait till you
see this Public Enemy CG face not so
great but I think if you didn't like
those I can show you something you do
like have you guys seen this no no check
this
out the hungry purple
dinosaur I know that girl yeah it's
Sophia Lis they
hung purple dinosaurs wow look at these
freaking volume capture face capture
shots man the information man look at
the jiggling that's crazy is it for sure
CG though it's so for sure CG this is
based on the whole metahuman framework I
already thought the man human stuff was
good like they already figured out how
to render it and make it look really
nice but I'm like okay this is this
feels like this just got kicked up a
whole another level so here here's the
question is this just volume capture of
the face like what they did in LA Noir
but in higher res which is cool but
frankly pretty limiting because you have
to have the actor inside this camera
sphere and they have to give a
performance which means you're by
yourself you're really forcing it but if
this is actually like a character model
that's being driven with animation like
with motion captured animation then
that's crazy seeing the skin flex and
move over the skeleton beneath cuz you
know this isn't like your surface your
surface is underneath all it this is
just like jiggly Jello-O on top like as
a plastic bag to hold it in place you
know like that's the physics that you
need to put into a face to have it not
be uncanny and you know no one does that
but this old guy is the greatest example
you know it's like his cheeks are
jiggling and his jbls are jiggling he's
like I'm acting and I'm having a
monologue and it's like wow Everything
feels alive you know that's why I think
it's volume capture cuz the eyes are
different but everything else is that
actor which which makes me think you
know maybe it is just a volume capture
it could be a volume capture to get the
motion capture data to drive the
separate model like that's a thing like
a lot of face capture these days are
multiple cameras in front of your face
like two infrared so you're always
getting like two angles you can always
make it more
accurate when she when she screams like
the shape of her mouth you can't get
that with like morph targets really you
have to like you have to get in there
but like then even like the muscles and
the way the lips stretch like I feel
like you can only get that these days
with with volumetric capture the way the
lips stick together Li stick yes that's
insane well did you see the blue dot
thing that these guys made the the the
reveal for The Meta human
animator PR yeah it already looks great
yeah it's insane right so this is
basically the last high-profile thing
that these guys did and this is the
reveal for the metahuman animator app
that came out if I was going to
criticize it I'm not totally sure where
I would start you know it's mostly one
of those oh you know it's CG therefore
you're like oh CG staring into faces of
basser by who should they ask all wet
this though like makes it out of The
Uncanny Valley for me I know it's not
real so I don't mean that it's tricking
me like that but I'm not uncomfortable
watching this at all I could watch a
feature like this no problem right I
could get fully invested in this guy
this looks good it looks great just like
the hide Kima trailer they're both at
that level where you're just like even
if I were to tell you it's all CG it's
like it stops mattering it's such a jump
what we just saw I mean this was such a
jump from before so maybe that's just
how insanely exponential this thing has
gotten is there anything behind the
scenes of this is there like nothing
it's it's classic Kima stuff where
they're like here's something no context
and then you're like 2 years later it's
like it's like H finally you know I like
I honestly I really want to figure out
how they made this and if you do too
well subscribe because once it's
revealed we'll tell you I think it's
worth pointing out too like Sam's been
actually experimenting with these new
animation systems and posting shorts on
the corridor Channel yeah and even
though Starfield you know is way past
its prime which is crazy considering it
came up this year uh but you know I
still had a lot of fun playing it and so
we made some shorts about Starfield so
if you've played that game enjoy it or
even like Bethesda games at all I think
you'd be in on the joke and they're on
the cter channel check them
out I've been pulled through time I
think you guys just like me and a lot of
other people are just a little burnt out
on Marvel but every time I open up a
Marvel thing it's like the the effects
the design everything is still just like
it's so top level and I saw some
comments saying we should check out the
ending of Loki season 2 the ending
spoilers so they have the the master
Loom which weaves the threads of the
Multiverse together and they have a way
of representing death on the show which
is basically the fabric of your reality
Coming Undone scientists say this by the
way if you're mul mess with too much
scientist say the very threads of your
fabric of reality can become unraveled
uhoh that's CRA SCI to say that dude oh
this is so this is real
yeah
my
w Funky
Man ooh I love it yeah wow I love it D
glass noodles it looks very cool so cool
so unique everything think's getting
hairy oh no he's hairy
too oh shoot it's like a g Light
commercial D I love the light coming out
of the TV oh my gosh wow it's kind of
mesmerizing isn't it I really like they
make the world actually spin here so the
threads follow the spin these are some
nice ass
shots there's so many ways to approach
this because you know you're looking at
these incredibly high density High
detail simulations and realistically if
you're using like quote unquote consumer
software to do this you're probably
going to use like hair physics basically
but then this is still in that whole
other it's like how do you get to move
properly and then dissolve and all that
stuff and just there's so many
challenges like the way it matches the
environment the tonality and the
lighting of the environment so perfectly
like the highlights the rolloffs the
reflections now these are like a Mastery
of animation and execution and
simulation and scripting but also like
the color science and the compositing
it's just like like they're like lens
the outut of focus nature of the glass
the glass in noodle form feeling like it
has the same physical characteristics as
the actual physical glass that was there
when you get to this kind of level with
this kind of intensity it's no longer
really a visual effect in my mind it is
Data manipulation I mean there really
are like scientists and Engineers who
are designing this in tandem with
artists it's it's really the hybrid of
science and art it reminds me of the
fact that there's a completely different
class of visual effects artists out
there that I do not interact with on a
day-to-day basis nor do we frankly have
here at the studio no one no one really
quite is at that level where you know
you we so used to opening visual effect
software and going like I wonder what
this button does I wonder what this
button does and then you have people
like this who go like I make the buttons
yes yes yes I could not agree more dude
this is the Pinnacle of a comic books
being turned into like TV shows and
movies and it's so funny we're so jaded
about it now cuz they've been given so
many gifts what it really comes down to
is if you have a really good team you
good directors producers supervisors
artists and you're all talking to each
other and you're all communicating and
you're there with each other every step
of the way I don't think feel like you
step backwards too often unless it's
something where all of you together are
like we can do better better let's step
backwards together I'm glad you said
that about the direction because the
director really does Drive the
cohesiveness of the visual effects and
the scope of the story so to speak
because it's very easy especially
nowadays for the visual effect scope to
get out of control and just be used for
everything but when you have a director
has a very specific vision and doesn't
want to lean on that crutch you can
typically get really good results which
oh perfect segue whoops uh Master and
Commander a hunter becomes the
haunted well then there's not a moment
to lose Master Commando came out in 2003
epic concept Peter wear was the director
in 2003 they didn't have the the crutch
of CGI and crazy ocean simulations and
stuff to lean on so they had to be
really creative in how they did this and
it's some of the best look in Ocean
stuff I've
seen did already the rotoscoping looks
like a
nightmare it looks like the real thing
it does it does that that shot is good
look at it there he is now I must say
that shot was amazing wait a minute how
do you get the camera to smoothly roll
through this that's got to be a comp
shot those waves aren't there when they
got this shot he is just standing on a
boat in a pool yeah they're not over the
radio like in the middle of like one of
the worst storms being like action lean
farther out wait for the big wave
Russell C farther out I love how it's
low visibility too like you really get
that low visibility like dizziness the
fog man the water wow that's all comp
water look at those ropes dude freaking
ropes Nightmare Man somebody's comping
like having to cut them
out wow that shot look at that shot my
my look at that that must be a mini this
this looks just fantastic doesn't it the
producers were leaning towards doing it
all digitally the director put his foot
down he said no no this needs to be
grounded the visual effects cannot draw
attention we need to do it practically
so they spent 10 days total filming out
on the water and then they turned to wet
a workshop who were just working I think
on the time or had just finished Return
of the King wet a workshop designed a
six model replica of the ship on a
gimbal on that they shot on blue screen
and then they have the PSD resistance
they built to scale another HMS surprise
wow surprise wow you look surprised they
built an entire another one from the
ground up but this one exist not top
down ground up and this one exist in the
same tank that they built to film
Titanic on a gimbal so they can
literally direct it however they need to
for all the wide shots insane it's nuts
man they did not use blue screen for
this stuff for all of the large scale
stuff they just said f it we're going to
Roto it cuz sometimes blue screen can be
more headache than it's worth you know
what I mean if you're seeing the edges
if you're seeing the rigging like that
becomes a bit of a nightmare so I think
they just they just said look let's just
R to it and then we're getting like
actual proper light rat we're getting
everything as it should be in camera and
and we'll let someone else worry about
about it down the line bless their art
supposedly there were like a ton of
viewings of this as as it was going on
and when he would see sequences with
visual effects inside sometimes there
were incredible wow moments for people
and he didn't like that because he's
like okay yeah it looks amazing but
let's dial it back because the story
needs to be the thing that sits on the
surface of these visual effects the
entire time we can't have any breakouts
that cause you to leave the theater
going did you see that wave shot no you
talking about the story if you want to
support what we do go subscribe at
Corridor digital.com WE Post these
episodes a day early there and with
extended content they each about half an
hour long so yeah go check it out cord
digital.com bye bye
bye I kind of like that